welcome to this new video on email
marketing for 2024 in 2019 a well-known
Fashion Boutique utilized targeted email
marketing to drive sales and engagement
so what was their approach they sorted
customers by purchase history and
preferences post which they tailored
emails with product recommendations and
discount they believed AB testing may
prove great for their business thus AB
tested subject lines for effect iveness
implemented workflows for abandoned
cards and follow-ups and monitored
metrics to optimize campaigns as a
result they observed 40% increase in
email open rates 35% boost in
click-through rates 25% rise in
conversion rates 20% increase in sales
revenue thereby achieving significant
sales growth and improved engagement
through targeted email marketing now you
must be curious to know more about email
marketing let's understand what is email
marketing but before we move ahead to
know in detail about email marketing if
you are the one who is looking to get
certified in 2024 then you are at the
right place introducing perue
postgraduate program in digital
marketing which will be your all over
companion with this program you will not
only ace in email marketing but also
keyword research search engine
optimization behavioral marketing
campaign management social media
marketing content marketing and much
more with this technical expertise you
will also gain complete Hands-On
learning with the tools like Google
Keyword Planner chat GPT Google ads
Google analytics and there are more than
30 tools in the list reserve your seats
first enroll now from the link in the
description box and pin comment so let's
start by understanding what is email
marketing at its scoree email marketing
is the art of leveraging email
communication to connect with the
targeted audience and achieving
marketing goals whether it's promoting
products sharing valuable content or
nurturing customer relationship ships
email marketing offers a direct and
personal channel for businesses to
engage with their Audience by building
and managing an email list crafting
relevant and engaging content and
analyzing data to refine strategies
business can drive conversion boost
brand awareness and Foster long-term
Customer Loyalty with its versatility
and Effectiveness email marketing
remains a Cornerstone of digital
marketing strategies providing
businesses with a powerful tool to reach
Their audience in an increasingly
crowded on online landscape email
marketers are always high in demand and
may grab a high paying career an email
marketing manager may earn up to 16 lakh
rupees per anom email marketing is the
need for all businesses trying to get
hold online some big giants hiring for
email marketers include Amazon HubSpot
Salesforce Shopify Facebook and Linkedin
so let's understand benefits of email
marketing for business growth here are
some some benefits of email marketing
when you consider choosing it for
business growth improving sales email
marketing enables businesses to promote
products or Services directly to Their
audience driving sales through targeted
offers promotions and exclusive deals
derived right to their inbox increase
leads by offering valuable contents or
incentives in exchange of email signups
businesses can effectively grow their
email list nurturing leads and
converting them into customers over time
through strategic email campaigns
communicate with audience email
marketing provides a direct and
personalized channel for businesses to
communicate with their audience keeping
them informed about new Products Company
updates or upcoming events generates web
traffic through compelling email content
and strategically placed call to actions
businesses can drive traffic to their
websites blog post or landing pages
increasing engagement and conversions t
targeting the Right audience with
Advanced segmentation and targeting
capabilities businesses can ensure that
their email messages reach to the most
relevant audience segment targeting the
Right audience with Advanced
segmentation and targeting capabilities
businesses can ensure that their email
messages reach the most relevant
audience segments at the optimal time
maximizing the chances of Engagement and
conversion reduce cost effective
campaigns compared to traditional
marketing channels email marketing
offers a high return of investment with
relatively low cost allowing businesses
to create an execute effective campaigns
without breaking the bank owning media
and contact list unlike social media
platforms or advertising networks
businesses have full control over the
email marketing assets including their
contact list and content distribution
providing greater autonomy and
flexibility increasing brand awareness
consistent and engaging email
communication helps businesses to
reinforce their brand identity and
messaging increasing awareness among
Their audience and fostering brand
recognition over the time creating
personalized content email marketing
allows businesses to tailor their
messages and content based on their
preferences behaviors and interests of
individual subscribers delivering a
personalized experience that resonates
with recipient and dri engagement
collecting feedback and surveys email
marketing provides a valuable platform
for businesses to gather feedback from
Their audience through surveys polls or
feedback forms enabling them to gain
insights improve products or services
and enhance customer satisfaction so
let's start by knowing top email
marketing strategies for 2024 on number
one we have is personalized email
content personalized email content in
subject lines and body content instead
of generic subject lines personalize
them based on subscriber preference or
behavior use Dynamic content to tailor
the email body to each recipient's
interest or past interactions with your
brand next is audience segmentation
segment your email list based on
demographics purchase history engagement
level or any other relevant criteria
create targeted campaigns for each
segment delivering content and offers
that resonate with their specific needs
and preferences autom email campaigns
set up an automated email sequence
triggered by subscriber actions or
Milestones such as welcome emails
abandon card reminders or post-purchase
follow-ups use email automation tools to
streamline the process and ensure timely
delivery of relevant messages track
important email metrics monitor key
email metrics such as open rates click
through rates conversion rates and
revenue generated use email analytic
tools to gain insight into subscriber
behavior and campaign performance
allowing you to make data driven
decisions and optimize your email
strategy accordingly send emails
strategically determine the optimal
timing and frequency for sending emails
based on your audience preferences and
behaviors experiment with different send
times and days of week to identify the
most effective sending schedules for
your target audience AB test test
different elements on your email
campaign such as subject clients ctas or
email copy to determine what resonates
best with your audience split your email
list into random segments and send
variations of your campaigns to each
engagement then analyze the result to
identify the winning variation last but
not the least leverage seasonality
tailor your email content and promotions
to align with seasonal events holidays
or Trends relevant to your audience
incorporate seasonal themes imagery and
offers to make your email timely and
engaging driving increased engagement
and conversions by implementing these
strategies you can create more
personalized targeted and effective
email campaigns that resonate with your
audience and drive better results for
your business if you like this video
give it a thumbs up and do not forget to
subscribe to Simply learn to stay
updated with latest Technologies thanks
for watching staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
Skilling whether you're a student aiming
to learn today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
IND histry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here